ron desantis
just keeps the hits on coming
the guy is in terms of governors in this
country the guy is doing
better than basically anybody he i don't
know how he's obviously running for
president so he's gearing all of his
actions toward that but it's great it's
really working he had this is my
favorite desantis moment yet
and it happened just yesterday at the
university of south florida
governor desantis was going up to give a
little talk do a little photo line and
he sees students
wearing the stupid masks and
ron desantis he chose his words very
carefully i think
he corrected these students and it's a
correction that the entire country
should hear
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take it off but honestly
it's not doing anything and we gotta
stop with this theater so if you want to
wear it fine but this is a this is
ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf oh
it's good to be at usf it's good to see
rhonda and then what do the kids do they
take it off of course they take it off
they wanted to take this off the whole
time but people in authority these petty
little tyrants like their professors and
these
deputy deans of diversity and inclusion
that now run all the campuses they won't
let them take it off
but then in walks mack daddy desantis
and he says hey take that off and what
he said was was really important he said
a couple things that were slightly
different here
he said
if you want to wear it fine whatever
but then he said please take it off
we've i was thinking of all the various
there's more than just two reactions on
the masks right it's it's more than just
do wear the mask don't wear the mask
some people say do wear the mask you
must wear the mask wear the mask all the
time
some people say wear the mask if you
want to that's your individual choice
whatever you want to do is totally fine
because you have total control over your
body and you should never be made to
wear something or not wear something
that you don't want to wear it's totally
up to you if you want to look like a
bandito in society fine if you want to
walk around with some filthy cloth
covering your whole face no big deal
wear the secular cafe whatever you want
individualism baby and then there's the
conservative answer which is take off
the stupid mask it doesn't do anything
it's disordered for our society to have
everyone wandering around like they're
about to rob a stagecoach don't do it
take it off it's dumb it's weird it's
wrong and it's not how society should
function
and desantis he gave a little hint at
the kind of weak squishy individual do
whatever you want kind of argument in
the middle which was look if you want to
wear it whatever but most of his
argument was
please take it off
it's beyond you don't need to wear it
you don't need to wear the mask please
take it off
please
we need to get past this covid theater
as long as there is a substantial
portion of americans wearing these
stupid masks we're not we're never going
to get past the covet theater
i'll give give you an example of this
my wife is a goes to certain classes
right
sweet little lacy you know she goes to
different classes sometimes with the
baby sometimes maybe it's an exercise
class this or that you've all seen this
in your own life too you go to a class
you go
to a community group you go to a meeting
no one wants to wear the mask
except for like one person like one
person
is sitting there and she's and and what
happens as a result of that one person
who wants to wear the mask everyone's
got to wear the mask
okay they're all sitting there you've
all got the dumb masks on because vouch
you made us wear it for two years and
then you sit there and you say okay and
it would people feel comfortable if we
do would you mind if maybe we took the
masks off and everyone says oh actually
yeah that would be i maybe i would like
and then there's that one person who
says actually guys
i'm um i'm super duper immunocompromised
i'm
i have my great-great-grandmother-in-law
lives three towns over from us and i
might see her in six months so you could
we all need to mask up forever please
and people do it and they go it's that
it's the tyranny of the minority in all
of these things ben sometimes talks
about this with vegetarianism and
families
everyone wants to eat meat in your
family everyone's having a nice time all
good lamb chops oh yeah nice steak
that's great except that one then
there's
your little sister
your little sister decides to become a
vegetarian and oh no don't worry guys
just me it'll just be me the vegetarian
and what happens all of a sudden
no one eats meat anymore or your meat
consumption dramatically dries the
tyranny of the minority do not let them
get away with this
the masks are dumb they're stupid they
have no basis in
prudence or
sense or reason
drop them as a as a cultural ritual
they're hideous and heinous all they
remind me of is the dictatorship of dr
fauci ditch him desantis totally right
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please ring the bell
subscribe
you can get all the notifications for
our videos and then head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch your google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show
leave a five star review if you wouldn't
mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]